hi everyone
my name is colin tanner i live in
marysville ohio i am 17 years old
and i'm a senior in high school i'm
going to talk a little bit
about my battle with cancer i'm a little
bit sore from my lung surgery a couple
weeks ago
my breathing's a little bit labored it's
a better way for me
i've started to have a lot of pain in my
right knee
over the summer of 2016. it was right
after i turned 13.
i was starting to grow a lot and i was
extremely active in sports and hanging
out with friends and stuff so i thought
i was just growing pains from activities
and everything
because i played lacrosse football
wrestling
i rode dirt bikes i surfed i snowboarded
i did everything that i could do
so i thought i had to deal with that but
i also had oshkosh waters
disease in my other knee so i thought
that could be that disease for me and my
rape is
right knee it's kind of like a growing
pain disease and it's not too bad
so cancer obviously was not a concern
but the pain got really bad a few weeks
before i was supposed to start
eighth grade um it was a couple days
before eighth grade
and i had to go in i got an x-ray of my
knee
and they immediately saw a growth that
worried them they sent me to get an mri
the same day
they called me down right away and they
sent me to the james cancer hospital
at ohio state a biopsy soon followed and
i was diagnosed with osteosarcoma in my
right knee
and my distal femur this all happened
over a few days span
and we were all in a bit of shock i
attended eighth grade
for one day and then i started chemo the
following one day
chemo was difficult but it didn't have a
lot of bad side effects the first time
around
i lost my hair and i gained a ton of
weight from steroids
and then after a month or two of chemo
i had a full knee replacement and
partial female replacement once the
tumor started to shrink some
i had over 100 stitches and i still have
a pretty impressive scar
that first year i also had my first
thoracotomy
and open lung surgery to remove tumors
from my lungs
after chemo was finished 10 months later
my scans looked clear and everyone
thought it was cancer free
i got to enjoy that feeling for a few
months until my next scan
when i learned the cancer had spread to
my lungs
it may have been there all along if so
it was just too small to be detected by
a scan
an osteosarcoma when cancer does spread
from the original spot and almost
always goes to the lungs the next three
to four years were kind of a blur for me
honestly
i went through three main protocol types
of chemo and three additional
types of oral chemotherapy i had five
thoracotomies and open lung surgeries
three in my right lung and two on my
left lung
last week last week i had a thoroscopy
a less invasive surgery to remove a
tumor on my left lung
i have had radiation on my right lung
and also my diaphragm
i'm starting radiation again two days on
my right lung
i've also had surgeries to lengthen my
prosthetic right
right femur since my left leg keeps
growing and my right leg cannot
the doctors have been able to control
the cancer and keep it
stable with chemo radiation and
surgeries
right now i am also taking an order of
chemo
combo medics it gives me a lot of skin
and pain issues in my hands and feet
but it helps control the growth of the
cancer we are
always keeping our eyes open for
clinical trials and other things that
could help me
luckily i do seem to respond well to
chemo and radiation so far
the cancer does keep coming back but of
course
we are hopefully we are hoping that
someday it will not
this is dexter after my first relapse i
was in the hospital for chemo and i was
starting to really want a dog of my own
i've always wanted a golden retriever
and i didn't think my parents would let
me get a dog right at that time
because i was in treatment i know some
people didn't think it's a great idea
to bring a new dog into a household
during treatment
but i made a powerpoint and it was a
proud point on why i think i actually
get a dog
and um my parents really liked the
powerpoint and that was a great idea
and it worked very quickly actually and
all my points worked and my parents
ended up getting me a dog
uh dexter's helped me so much he's made
life amazing he is
my amazing three-year-old golden
retriever um
and so i got involved with canines and
kids a few years ago
i became a child ambassador for them um
and i've learned a lot about how similar
that dog cancer human cancer is
and especially uh in bone cancer for
dogs and humans which is what i have
personally by studying cancer dogs we
can help a
make a ton of progress for dogs and for
kids
and humans with cancer and it'll help
both of them at the same time
because i know that it's i've read that
about of all the dogs that live 10 years
or more
about 50 of them get cancer in their
lives and most people
almost everyone that i know considers
their dog part of their family
and if canine research can help dogs and
your family members
why would you not do it because you have
both at the same time
i like thank you all for listening to my
story and i'd like to thank canines and
kids
for having me thank you
i am anne graham with mib agents
we are honored today to introduce you to
colin
his epic battle with osteosarcoma has
been one he has fought
with courage and tenacity
we at mib agents look forward to the day
when such fortitude and perseverance
are not required of any child facing
osteosarcoma
thank you for being here and for using
your powers for good
to make it better for osteo warriors
like colin
thank you colin for sharing your story
you and dexter
inspire phoebe and i to make it better
by crushing cancer
at both ends of the league
all right i want to thank colin and anne
for sharing their story with us
and thank all of you for being here
today for our discussion about
research in sarcomas that has bridged
the gap between humans and pediatric
patients
and uh our canine companions
i have the honor to introduce to you a
friend of mine dean lee
he is a physician
caring for children in our transplant
unit at nationwide children's but spends
a lot of his time
as the leader of an osu ohio state
nationwide children's initiative
in cellular therapies and that's where
his research lies he was a pioneer
in developing ways for expanding natural
killer cells which is an immune cell
that
can attack human tumors
and i'm excited to hear what he has to
say go ahead dean
hi thanks so much for the opportunity to
talk about our work in nk cell
immunotherapy for canine osteosarcoma
appreciate the organizers of the paws
for a cure symposium
um for this for this opportunity
so i just wanted a couple of disclosures
i
serve on the scientific advisory board
and have some ip
and consulting for chiatas pharma
caribou biosciences and courier
therapeutics
regarding their approaches for human and
k cell development
bone marrow transplant has often been
considered the original cell therapy
in this approach we try to increase the
amount of chemotherapy and radiation
that are delivered to a patient
and then rescue that patient by
providing a nice healthy bone marrow
from a donor this allows us to deliver
higher doses of chemotherapy and
radiation than we would normally be able
to do
without this rescue
e donald thomas is often considered the
father of bone marrow transplantation he
worked
on this approach in the late 1940s and
actually won the nobel
prize in 1990 for the dog models that he
used
to establish this and he used an old
world war ii bunker as his dog a
radiator
and as of late last year last time i did
the search
there were over 500 patients on the
canine leukocyte antigen
and over well over a thousand papers on
canine bone marrow transplantation
for humans this is really an important
part of our therapy for leukemias and
you can see in the graph on the right
that we
perform in the tens of thousands of
allergenic transplants every year where
we deliver in case
we deliver bone marrow from
a different person an allergenic person
um and then
we also do 10 or 15 000 um transplants a
year where we give back that same
person's
bone marrow in non-leukemia settings
like in solid tumors
in in the dog canine lymphosarcoma
has is commonly treated by a bone marrow
transplant but we do have a lot of
experience in this area
however what we've learned about
transplants over the last 20 years
especially is that it's not about the
high dose chemotherapy and radiation
it's actually because you're delivering
a new immune system
and that immune system has a lot of
different components in this particular
figure
the natural killer cellar nk cell is
shown in the middle
the nk cell has this direct ability to
see
and kill tumor cells but it also has
this ability to release things called
cytokines which communicate to all the
rest of the
um the immune system to develop
a response against the tumor
in leukemia this is hampered by the fact
that the bone marrow is infiltrated by
the leukemia and you can't make
nk cells very well in addition many
tumors including leukemias
suppress the natural killer cells by
producing things like
tgf beta a protein called ido
and there's a variety of checkpoint
inhibitors that suppress immune
responses in general and then we give
chemotherapy and radiation and we wipe
out
every last nk cell that's left because
they're very sensitive to chemo and
radiation
so this has created a an opportunity we
see
that if we could restore nk cell number
and function after these kinds of events
we might be able to improve
already good therapies to make them even
better
we did this by developing an approach
for growing nk cells
where we would send a donor to the blood
bank have them
collect the blood just like you would if
you were giving a blood donation at the
blood bank
we select the white blood cells off of
the top of that something called the
buffy coat fraction
get rid of the t cells because they get
in the way a little bit um
through something called cd3 depletion t
cells have cd3 on them and
get rid of them and then we grow the nk
cells to large numbers
by stimulating them once a week um with
these antigen presenting cells that
we've
engineered to have all the right
proteins to stimulate nk cells to
proliferate and divide
we can then infuse that as a fresh
product or cry preserve it and infuse it
later which is really important when we
start talking about getting to a
universal donor product
these nk cells are very potent in
recognizing cancer and we've shown that
they can recognize and kill lymphoma
multiple types of leukemia including aml
solid tumors including neural crest
tumors like neuroblastoma
and bone tumors like osteosarcoma
and carcinomas in adults melanoma colon
cancer pancreatic cancer
breast uterine brain tumors almost every
kind of cancer
that you can imagine we've been able to
identify
ones that are sensitive to nk cells so
this is
um these little nk cells interacting
with a brain tumor called
atrt and you can see that once they've
decided that this is a bad
tumor it's really a matter of seconds
for them to
release the granules of perforin and
granzyme that are necessary to pop a
hole in the cancer cell
and make it die so in
the humans we've completed now several
clinical trials
with our feeder cell i'll 21 expanded nk
cells we've treated about 80 patients in
total
a couple of dozen patients in matched
transplant settings for
myeloid malignancies a couple of dozen
patients in haplotransplants
and a couple of dozen patients outside
of the transplant setting in patients
who have
very resistant and refractory uh
leukemia
to try to get them in remission so that
they could be eligible for a transplant
and in this
setting this is where we're delivering
the nk cells right after chemotherapy
to try to help restore nk cell function
and then we've also tried a couple of
trials one that's been completed where
we've grown a patient's
own nk cells and delivered those back in
this case
actually in infusions into the brain for
patients with brain tumors
the problem with autologous nk cell
therapies
is that it takes a long time to grow
these cells and
the autologous nk cells are are not
quite as effective
the allogeneic ones also take a while to
grow and identify the donor
so what would really be ideal is if we
could identify
the ideal donors of nk cells and grow
banks of those cells that they would
already be ready to
thaw and infuse at the bedside something
that we call a universal donor
approach in a transplant setting when
we've given these cells after transplant
compared to historical controls
we've seen a decrease in relapse rates
from 30 percent
down to less than 10 and overall
survival has increased from 65 percent
uh to almost 90. adding those nk cells
has also made complications of
transplant better we see less gbh and we
see fewer viral
infections less vk virus and cmv virus
so in solid tumors one of the things
that we need to do is to overcome
the immunosuppression as i mentioned in
the early slide
from something called tgf beta and you
can see here this is a wide range of
different tumor types and how much
tgf beta they make in particular
osteosarcoma here
and chondrosarcoma the sarcomas are way
on the high end of how much tgf beta
they make
so this is really going to be an issue
when the nk cells are given to these
patients
can they actually overcome tgf-beta
inside these
these solid tumors well to address this
a graduate student in my lab jennifer
fultz worked on making nk cells
resistant to tgf beta through this
process called tgf beta
imprinting and here we can see that by
doing this
the nk cells now make really high levels
of cytokines
and in the dotted line this is with when
you add the tgf beta
that hardly changes it at all so they
really become resistant to tgf beta
especially during this first couple of
weeks after we do the imprinting
and the reason they're resistant to tgf
beta is because they've lost a
particular protein called saman 3 which
is essential for tgf-beta's signaling
so applying this now to the dog we
decided we would try this
in canine osteosarcoma because it's such
a good model for
for pediatric sarcoma this is
an osteosarcoma in in a um
a young adult uh down here um next to
the ankle actually in this case
and this is in the long bone sorry
this is in the dog and then on the right
hand side is in
is in a teenager they have a similar
appearance
on x-ray imaging they have similar
genetics
they have similar prognosis and even
have similar complications
such as the metastasis that this has to
the lung is usually
the main complication for both young
adults
and for for dogs with this disease
so so to do this we had to first
identify nk cells in the dog and this
was done
again by dr fultz when she was doing her
phd degree
she identified that you could find nk
cells in the dog but on the basis of
their expression of this
gene ncr 1 also known as nkp 46
and that the the in sorry
that the nk cells in dogs um had
all the same canonical um receptor
expression as what we would expect them
to have in humans
and so she made an antibody to nkp 46 so
that we could
see and isolate nk cells in dogs and see
if they would grow the same way that we
grow our human nk cells
and so sure enough she was able to show
that that cd3
marks dogs t cells down here and then
nkp 46
and the lack of cd3 would mark an nk
cell
population that normally in the dog is
about 5
of their lymphocytes but after um 14
days of expansion or 21 days of
expansion would get to be 80 or 90
of their growth so we would eliminate
almost all of the t cells and we'd have
this nice pure population
of dog nk cells that could be used um to
infuse back to them
she showed that they had high
cytotoxicity against
um canine osteosarcoma cell lines the
cell line called gray
oscar 8 and oscar 40 are all very
sensitive to these
cells and and killed by them
we then worked with um another graduate
student uh chanera peck
who helped us identify which breeds
should we try to get these cells from
and what we ended up with was really
identifying the most consistent donor
was the greyhound
and had high levels of all of the
expressions
of um of these receptors that we needed
so we now have a very similar platform
for growing canine nk cells
as we did for human nk cells and to do
this
we collect the canine blood uh
re do the buffy coat just like we do it
in a human
and instead of cd3 we use cd5 for
depletion to get rid of the t
cells do the same kind of stimulation
with this special feeder cell
and can cryopreserve and make banks of
these cells that are ready to thawing
and fuse
we've worked hard to make this a
clinically appropriate
process for the dog where we can do it
all in a closed system
using something called the miltenny
prodigy
that has all these tubing sets and bags
and culture chambers that keeps it all
nice and sterile
we do this for the first week and then
we transfer this for the second and
third week to grow the cells
in in a large bioreactor called the wave
that is
um that is made by a company called
sativa
so the clinical trial that we developed
with dr bill kissabirth
in the veterinary school at ohio state
university
involves in multiple infusions of these
allergen egg off the shelf
and k cells right around the time of the
amputation
and this is to try to prevent any
seeding that would happen to the lungs
as a as a part of this amputation
process
then the dogs go on to get carboplatin
in multiple cycles which would be their
typical therapy so
very widely accepted therapy of
amputation followed by four cycles of
carbo
but after each cycle of this
chemotherapy we're going to deliver
multiple infusions of the nk cells to
help
quickly restore their nk cell function
and so in this
old treatment cycle each dog will
receive up to 11 infusions
of nk cells progress to date we've
established a bank
um as a bank source of these canine tgf
beta
imprinted and k cells we've optimized
the t cell depletions
process and developed closest to
manufacturing which i mentioned
and this has really given us this
outbred validation of a universal donor
and
k cell and validating our production of
these tgf beta and printed nk cells
we've also gone through a process of
developing a serum free media
and cryopreservation so we can eliminate
the need for
other sources of serum where we would
commonly use fetal bovine serum
the trial is open in accruing we've done
three expansions
uh so far at a clinical large scale
grade we've developed 51 bags of nk
cells
for a total of 770 million in k-cells
almost a billion in k-cells that we've
manufactured
they're very high purity of nk cells
more than 90 percent
express nkp 46 very low cd3 content
less than one percent we've treated two
patients and done a total of 15
infusions so far
we have had two infusion reactions and
both of those were tolerable
um with some pre-medication where they
went on to receive
additional infusions without a problem
so kind of where do we go next um we
really would like to see
where these nk cells go we've worked a
little bit on a process
that involves some 19 fluorine imaging
this seems to work but it has a low
sensitivity
so in the last couple of months thanks
to dr straub and harkey at the fred
hutchinson cancer center we validated an
assay for
a vnt archimerism assay and we're now
working on some new protocols in canine
melanoma and canine
lymphoma so just thanks to
so many people who made this possible a
couple people in the lab
mason has been working on the 19
fluorine imaging ani is the one who has
made all of the clinical
nk cells that we've infused yasmin is
the person who's been developing our
vntr assay shelly watts is our program
manager who's really helped with all the
logistics
of this process and jennifer fultz is a
graduate student
who really helped develop the nkp 46
antibody and the
expansion process for dogs so that we
could deliver this therapy
to our canine friends thanks very much
for
your attention and i'll join the
discussion session
later on after this to answer any
questions
thank you dean for your presentation
it's been fun to watch that project
develop and uh
i appreciate you sharing it with us
today
we look forward to seeing the results of
those studies i want to remind
participants that as dean mentioned we
will be having
a session for questions and answers at
the end of this
series of presentations so if you have
questions that you'd like answered
please feel free to submit them
in the box at the side
we'll now have the pleasure to hear from
dr stephen dao
and cheryl london dr dao is from
the colorado state university and dr
london from tufts
they've been working together for
several years now
on immunotherapeutic approaches to the
treatment
of several different types of canine
cancers
and have been great collaborators with
our children's oncology group and other
pediatric based oncology clinical trials
organizations
so we'll be delighted to hear some
updates on some of the work that they've
been doing
good morning everybody and thanks again
to the organizers for the opportunity to
present
our work at this uh symposium this will
be
a dual presentation um i'm going to
start off the first half
i'm steve dow from the flood animal
cancer center at you
and then cheryl london at the tough
school of that med
will follow up the second half so we're
going to give you an overview of the
work we've been doing to
optimize novel immunotherapy
combinations
to really target the tumor micro
environment and we're using
the dog osteosarcoma model to really
interrogate these various
immunotherapy combinations
and they're targeting the immune
landscape
is always challenging there's lots of
targets to go after in the different
micro environment
and we know that osteosarcoma is
typically an immunologically
cold tumor so one of the
targets for that particular tumor is
cells in the tumor microenvironment may
be making the tumor
cold and really the for us the primary
target is going to be myeloid cells
within the tumor micro environment and
the two majors we're targeting are the
tumor-associated macrophages and then
also the inflammatory monocytes that
give rise to the macrophages and then
also the myeloid derived
suppressors component which is really a
combination of both neutrophilic
mdscs and monocytic mdscs so
the drugs that we'll be investigating
are all
targeted in ways of these primary
populations
and our hypothesis would be that if you
can
either deplete these cells or somehow
alter their function
that in turn you could reverse this
immunologically cold
tumor micro environment that's typical
of osteosarcoma
and make the tumor then more susceptible
to
other immunotherapy combinations
so um the first theme of the of the
studies and these are studies
funded through the moonshot initiative
are to evaluate these microenvironment
modifying immunotherapies get this thing
of chemotherapy resistant
macroscopic these are tumors that have
spread to the lungs and they can be
visualized and measured
using conventional chest radiographs so
the immunological
targets that we're going after include
the sticks that i've listed here
and i should point out that in most
instances we're trying these drugs we're
trying to repurpose
already approved drugs so they can be
rapidly advanced to the clinic
you'll see drugs on this list that are
used for a number of other diseases
but we've we and others have screened
[Music]
scenes of these already approved drugs
and identified
several that are really really
attractive and
in in some cases quite potent
immunological activity
primary targets include the ccr2
molecule which is a receptor expressed
by inflammatory molecules
which they need be recruited to tumors
what we're using to target that is the
starting which is
an angiotensin receptor blocker and we
published a
study this year indicating that losartan
has
off-target effects not only
does it block the ancient receptor but
also antagonizes
we're also targeting vegeta scepter and
flit 3 and that's a
an approved drug for dogs it's a
tyrosine kinase inhibitor
which is used to treat some cancers
directly but
we think it also has these immunological
off-target effects which makes it
interesting to us
drugging also gp 130 which is important
for io six tingling another
canine approved drug oxidative which is
actually
used widely by dermatologists um but
we're using it again because of its
immunological properties
another target is the cr1 and 2
which are important for il-8 signaling
and this is
a drug ladder rickson which is in late
stage development
for a variety of human
cancers is not improved yet
but is a drug um very closely related to
rhetoric and which is approved
likely to make it to the market soon i
should point out that all four of the
drugs i've just talked about
and the sixth drug are all orally
available
and we've also used the conventional
cytotoxic chemotherapy drug doxorubers
to produce antigenic cell death
liberating tumor energy
and then the final drug is proper law
which is
as most of you will know is an old beta
blocker
adrenergic um spelling and
there's a number of recent studies that
indicate that adrenergic activation is
really important
for mobilizing mds and also
stimulating their function so the
strategy we're using here is to
conduct rapid screening pilot studies
and in runs of small numbers of dogs
five different animals per group
again with measure lesions so that
really the outcome here is
whether the measurable lesions can be
altered
if the treatments don't pass this hurdle
then they don't make it to the
second phase of these trials which is we
investigate these drugs
in a adjuvant study
so it's an important point to make here
also is all these
various immunotherapy combinations have
been first validated in mouse studies so
one lasagna has been used by a number of
investigators to
modulate tumor growth in the micro
environment
what i'm showing here is that
windows um
reasonableness in mice lisatin does slow
tumor growth
uh this in this case this is metastatic
breast cancer
so it has activity but again it's like
unlikely to be fully active
on its own so but it's still an
attractive target
because of its um good safety
margin ready bioavailability as an oral
drug
one of the things we've learned in these
studies in dogs
was that the dose required to modulate
the mic the functionality of canine
monocytes particularly their migration
ability is much higher than the dose
required to modulate hypertension
so the off target effect requires a 10x
increase in losartan dosing but
importantly this
dose is also still well tolerated so
we've not
any evidence of hypotension
or of or other significant adverse
events from these
really high doses of loss this 10x dose
of oral losartan
is active in terms of blocking monocyte
migration
and also increasing the concentrations
of
ccl2 which is the ligand that binds to
the ccr2 receptor which is b
so the we used um we we actually
conducted two trials and dogs with one
trial with high dose
the start and another with the low dose
or the conventional dose
in combination with the drug tessera the
tyrosine kinase inhibitor
what i'm showing you here are results of
the first study with low-dose losartan
where we really
didn't see any evidence of significant
biologic activity in terms of tumor
regression
compared to the high-dose losartan where
we do see
four animals that really met the
criteria for partial responses
which is i should point out actually a
really important endpoint
because this tumor is very refractory to
any conventional treatments that
attempted in the past
so once dogs go through adjuvant
chemotherapy and develop
lung metastasis there really
are no good options there's nothing
that's been to date shown to work
then the dogs typically have a survival
of about two to three months
so we're very very encouraged to see
actual overt lesion regression in these
dogs this is
this dog was actually um had to be
euthanized because of
another disease but were able to go in
and look at the lesion lungs you see
it's
largely replaced by inactive stroma with
very few
living tumor cells and you can see the
tail
the survival in dogs um based on whether
they're getting higher low dose lossart
so i'm going to give you the um sort of
the overall study calendar for dogs of
osteo and this is
the product will be followed and then
i'm going to
just give you the results of the first
trial which was the combination
net network to serenity which is the
canine equivalent showing that
we see significant activity in animals
with high-dose losartan in terms of
numbers of partial responses his
overall clinical benefit of 40 and all
these dogs and
just one last point to make here is the
progressive free survival is not
different between these groups which is
a little bit
um or odd or unexpected but i think the
reason is
is because the first several animals
that we enrolled in this trial
i actually got two graphs of tweaks
instead of the typical
four weeks in in several of these dogs
we actually saw
here that the tumor progression was in
terms of
increasing lesion size but in retrospect
it was likely
pseudo progression due to increasing
inflammation around the tumor
the point being is that these early
biomarkers
apparently were changed in size for
example
should not be used as biomarkers to
establish progression because all of the
dogs where we saw pseudo progression
actually
then regressed and continued to have
longer survivals
so i'm going to stop there and we'll
hand it over to dr
london who will take you through the
rest of the trials that have
been conducted thank you steve
so the next trial really revolves around
two targets that really came about from
joint work done
in both dogs and in people so a couple
years ago
work led by chancana enlisted peony
identified
ile as a prognostic indicator in dogs
with osteosarcoma
where high levels were associated with a
negative
prognostic outcome essentially
and more recently there's some data that
has been associated
with dogs with osteosarcoma showing that
il-8 levels
are high in dogs compared to mass normal
control but
certainly ila turned out to be an
important player
in the realm of outcomes with respect to
the dogs with
with this osteoporosis that generated by
dr ryan robert
who showed that um i elevate the levels
of aisle eight
and aisle thick uh were associated with
metastatic lesion
the lung in human patients and this is
based on
uh qrt ptr data so really there was an
axis of
aisle six and il-8 signaling that seemed
to
be important in um outcomes with respect
to both dogs
and people
um around that time uh there was a
company called dampi that was developing
il-8 receptor inhibitors and these the
inhibitors really target
both of the ila receptors the x01 and
big r2
with the goal of modulating uh the
axis of eventually the tumor cells
themselves that sometimes express these
receptors as well as
the monocyte and macrophage population
that are
modulating the microenvironment uh and
there are two drugs
in this class in phydonte one is riparix
then the other one is ladderic
and laterans that actually has a much
longer half-life when given orally
um so it was an appealing drug to think
about translating
into the clinic some additional data
that was generated by dr
robert um in collaboration with our
laboratory
showed that if you co-block exactly
co-inhibit
gp 130 signaling or ielts thick
signaling and aisle a signaling
it really blocks lung seating in mouse
models of osteosarcoma so this is
an example where you can target both at
the same time of lungs eating you can
really prolong
survival of the ice um and then you can
actually show that this work
across species this mouse line that
would do for lungs
and then two dog osteosarcoma spell
lines that which belongs to
so the co-inhibition of ielts and il-8
really did inhibit the ability of those
tumor cells to
actually instead of stop in the long row
um and so this really was genesis or the
second trial which was
inhibiting ielts thick then txtr1 ii
we're using later extent and i'll stick
to using alpha system
and we elected to combine this with
oxygen to
essentially help induce antibiotic cell
death so we did a phase one study sort
of lead in study of bladdering then
identified a dose of 15 milligrams per
kilogram twice a day that was deficient
in inhibition migration in dogs
um we used the standard dose development
system uh which is twice per day
which was known to inhibit ielts
signaling uh based on previously
published barcode data and then a
relatively low dose of dog scriptures
with the goal of really
getting enough antibiotical death to
help prime the immune system when we
were sufficiently inhibiting
the tumor micro environment component
this was a planned every 21 day cycle uh
the doctors were given every 21 days
these were given continuously but
unfortunately all the dogs entered into
the cohort
had pretty rapid progressive defeat that
the first respect
so we immediately closed that cohort
down
and that led us to really the next pope
um
which was the combined uh lost ladder
extended to steroid import
board and this really arose um
really as a joint effort between the
myself
and some of the foundational data that
was driven
by um ryan robert's work and other
with respect to the role of ile and we
sort of hypothesized
as we're working together that we're
getting good good activity with the
sternum and lost
but that there might be an escape route
or some of that
immune micro environment by virtue of
aisle eight expression
and so we elected to add a later
accident into that combination and that
really has been a place where we've seen
improvement and outcome where
we're still early days though we've only
enrolled six patients today in cohort
but it's been actually quite encouraging
we've had two partial responses free
stable disease and one is too early for
assessment
um but these are the survival times per
day
basically by day what you can see is
essentially everybody's still alive
and we have dogs that are out several
months um and we're getting
really patterns of really nice stable
disease which you can see here
so this was uh at the outset of
treatment and then two months later here
are two
genes that are smaller and many of them
are just sitting there
sometimes the smaller ones tend to go
away this is a pattern that we've seen
throughout all of these patients um and
then here's another example of where we
actually had a complete response of a
lesion in one of the dog
over time and you could that within a
couple of months of treatment
uh this was actually by two months i've
picked up one of the lesions that
completely resolved with some others
still being there
and smaller so this uh current trial
with the combination of low start
laboratory assertive is looking quite
promising right now
okay so um we are now finishing up the
third trial and plan to finish enrolling
a total of ten dogs and then trial four
enrollment is ongoing at colorado state
with a plan to enroll
ten dogs uh using propanolol instead of
latarixan and
i think what you can see from the work
that we've done is that we actually have
some very promising results
uh using losartan tocerinib as the
foundation
of our immunotherapy strategy and
the nice thing about this is both
losartan and to sternum has been
mentioned
are already approved drugs that are easy
to get
uh and importantly at least with respect
to theranev there's a human counterpart
vietnam
as was mentioned that can be readily
incorporated so
our goal is to really take the last two
studies
uh finish doing uh the finished
enrolling and following those patients
out to evaluate their outcome and then
doing an analysis of the correlative
biomarkers which include
use of the new canine io nanostring
panel
on the pvmcs that we have collected if
we can identify
changes in ppmcg expression patterns
that are associated with
outcome in our patients as well as
plasma cytokine expression
and we're also doing some correlated
work associated with
uh circulating tumor dna from the the
structure
that we've collected uh sell free dna
from
um and then lastly really our goal is to
perform
a prospective study in dogs with
osteosarcoma using one of the triple
drug regimen
alone or in combination with
carbohydrate chemotherapy
and the decision about what sort of
third agent
ad and that triple drug therapy will be
made once we have finished
uh both the biomarkers and the
last two trials so uh with that i'd like
to acknowledge everybody at carl's date
um and toss yours involved in work the
nih
for supporting us through the cancer
moonshots uh
and in particular the cancer moonshot
group and precinct
and then all the other affiliates that
have helped us with this
uh including donpey who have been kind
enough to donate drugs
the other thing i would mention is that
this work really has been
a collaborative endeavor and i think
with
a number of stakeholders in the field
and including
our people who work on the human side
ryan roberts who
uh some of his data really
foundationally helped contribute to
the most recent drug treatment regimen
where we see the
so truly a team-based effort thank you
thanks cheryl uh it's been fantastic to
be a part of that team
and to see that data develop as well i
think
this is a great example of how ideas
and thoughts have worked their way back
and forth both from bench to bedside
and from human to dog and i'm excited to
see where that
where those trials are going um
next we'll have the opportunity to hear
from another
uh human and veterinary uh
collaborative collaborating pair we'll
get to hear from amy leblanc you've
heard from her already during this
conference
she is the director of the
comparative oncology program at the
national cancer institute
and has overseen the comparative
oncology trials consortium now for
several years
they've been the sponsors and and the
organizers of several of the trials
that you've seen over the last few days
her personal interests though have long
been those of imaging
and different ways that we can image
different cancers
and she's been working together with dr
alex wong
who is a professor of pediatrics at case
western reserve
university in northern ohio
he has a particular expertise
in immuno oncology and molecular
mechanisms
of immune sensitivity
and has been collaborating with dr
uh with dr leblanc on some imaging
studies that they'd like to share with
us today
can we start dr leblanc and dr wong's
video
well good afternoon my name is alex
huang i'm from case western reserve
university school of medicine
professor of pediatrics my pleasure to
have this session with amy leblanc from
nci to discuss
a emerging new compound that we're
trying to test to
boost the immune responses in
osteosarcoma the compound's name is
vg34200 we're targeting myeloid
functions within the tumor microwave
environment
iso sarcoma obviously is a well-known
entity to this group
it's the most common malignant bone
tumor for pediatric and aya
population metastatic disease
occurs frequently and unresectable
pulmonary metastatic disease has very
poor outcome
and so it clearly uh presents us a
clinical need
now in in our field historically we have
focused primarily on tumor intrinsic
vulnerabilities within the biology of
the cancer itself
in terms of genetic alterations in cell
cycle progression
protein synthesis and metabolic pathways
as well as nutrient responses and stress
and these are coming um the flavors of
chemotherapy surgery and radiation
however uh recently we have continued to
really
uh understand more on the complexity of
the the tumor itself
they encounter uh includes two image
extrinsic vulnerabilities
and i'll focus today primarily on our
efforts to
create new opportunities for
understanding and
mediating immune suppression invasion
and resistance as a pathway
to treat cancer within the tumor
microenvironment specific for
osteosarcoma
the humor cells are obviously composed
as part of the
tumor mass however it also contains of
myriads of host arrived elements
including
angiogenesis and stromal development and
in particular to today's conversation
on hematopoietic immune cells that
infiltrate the tumor micro environment
specifically
the myeloid cells encompasses macrophage
dendritic cells
and myeloid suppressor suppressor cells
and different than adele tumors many of
the pediatric tumors osteosarcoma being
a prototypic type um they have
relatively few
uh immune t cell infiltrations uh as
compared to adults
however uh pediatric tumors by and large
has higher
uh degree of myeloid cell infiltrations
as you know that here in cd68
and clinical observations have shown
that increased infiltration of
macrophages and dendritic cells
part of the myeloid hematopoiesis
is correlated with poor clinical outcome
suggesting that these
cells function to suppress the host
response to eradicate the tumor
and somehow by targeting these myeloid
cells it might be a potential
vulnerabilities that we can
exploit so within these hostile tumor
microenvironment
either at the primary bone tumor site or
in
metastatic sites such as the lungs or
elsewhere
the tumor itself does not exist um
de novo however he also uh
you know connects with a variety of
different cells including tumor
associated macrophages they know that
here is an
m2 macrophage and regulatory t
cells and other cellular components
right from the hematopoiesis
and today we'll focus on our recent
effort trying to target
and convert the functionality of these
tumor associated macrophages from a
tumor suppressive
um immune suppressive phenotype to a
inflammatory phenotype
so what is vg 34200 it is a naturally
derived compound that's isolated from
the outer shell of oak brand
and is purified by a variety of
purification methodologies
when purified it can be it's highly
water soluble
and bg34 derives from the structural
component of
what beta 1 4 and 1 3 linkages
of the sugar moiety a variety
of molecular weight ranges can be
isolated from hplc
and bg 34200 denotes a specific
200 kilodalton polymer of linear chain
bg34
we have shown previously in
collaboration with maizang in biomedical
engineering at
uh case western reserve the bg-34 by
itself has
high anti-tumor efficacy
using genetic mouse model shown here is
b16 melanoma
where uh injection the melanoma and
treatment subsequent to that
with bg 34 intravenously
can reduce the growth of the primary
tumor
dramatically as compared to other glucan
compounds
similarly prepared and this particular
activity is strictly related to the 200
dalton molecular weight range whereas 10
or 500
did not result in similar rejections of
tumor this not only have effect on the
primary tumor site as denoted here
but also have metastatic disease
suppression as they know
in panel e this led to overall
improved survival of mice treated with
bg-34
and in both male and female mice um
there is a plateau of dose efficacy of
bg34
between 550 milligrams per kilo to 100
milligrams per kilo
and this is again showing a dose
response um
when the those can be given repeatedly
over a course of a week
with the minimal toxicity in terms of
hematologic
parameters we have applied bg34 in the
treatment of syngenetic mouse model of
osteosarcoma
using k7m2 as a model system shown here
is a tracking of the metastatic disease
using the surface imaging showing that
after two months of
iv injections of of osteosarcoma k7m2
cell lines and start treatment with bg
34 weekly
a week after inoculation of the tumor we
can eradicate pretty much
the entire population of pulmonary
metastatic disease in this particular
model
and when we perform high high
dimensional multivariate
flow cytometry analysis we show that
bg34 specifically solicited
a in a dose-dependent manner a
population of myeloid cells immobilized
from the bone marrow as well as can be
isolated in the tumor micro environment
suggesting that bg34 interacts somehow
directly with
these myeloid cells to change its
function
and this is correlated with inflammatory
chemokine and increased t cell
infiltrations and cytotoxicity of the
resultant t
cells in vitro in macrophage under
m2 polarizing conditions vg34 reduces
the amount of arginase one one of the
markers for m2
as well as other phenotypes associated
with m2 like
macrophages and conversely increases the
m1 like
phenotype which is not shown here
in terms of pharmaceutical kinetics when
you label the bg-34 with a fluorescent
marker af647
what we see is the alpine injections iv
of bg34
we can pick up accumulation of the
fluorescent molecules uh signals
within the lungs as well as the spleen
a bone marrow and a tumor micro
environment within 24 hours
and this uptake of the fluorescent
signal is dependent on the expression of
cd11b
in the host of hematopoietic cells as
the 11b
narcotics fail to accumulate the signal
suggesting cd11b molecules is important
for the subtake
and upon in vivo injection into a
tumor-bearing mouse we can see the
signal
accumulate within the tumor micro
environment itself 24 hours after iv
administration
and within the tumor micro environment
if you look carefully you can
actually see inclusion of bg34 within
acidity of mmb positive cells as well as
some of the cb11b positive c lmc
positive dendritic cells and in fact
what we saw uh to summarize
is that bg34 administration a point 11b
binding
induces a tumor from a cold tumor into a
hot tumor
comprised of a increased t-cell
infiltration and cytotoxicity resulting
in tumor rejection
we also showed that bg34 itself can be
active against canine osteosarcoma cell
lines
shown even though the kpg-34 itself does
not have any direct
limitation to proliferation in vitro
against canine osteosarcoma
however in vivo in the immune deficient
mouse that still has
a myeloid function injections of bg-34
can dramatically reduce the amount of
canine osteosarcoma metastatic disease
in the lungs
in terms of the number of tumors in the
lungs and average size of the lung
nodules
and overall tumor surface occupies the
lung
tissue and this can be also validated
using a
marker specifically for the canine
osteosarcoma
using rt-pcr so i'll hand over to
amy about some of our emerging work uh
in in terms of clinical trial concepts
using bg bg34 and k9
amy thank you thank you so i can say
again my name is amy leblanc from the
nci comparative oncology program and
we are incredibly excited to partner
with alex on this concept
um it's no you know surprise to this
audience that again as
um alluded to earlier in our meeting
that um there are very strong
comparative molecular features that are
shared between humans and dogs
um and also within the tumor micro
of the primary tumor but also in
metastatic lesions we see similarities
that are
really exciting opportunities for future
study
um and so we know that dogs have
a complement of immune targets and have
good characterization
of their immune cells that support these
types of concepts
and to help validate these mechanistic
opportunities between
canine and human osteosarcoma patients
so not only do they share similarities
in the peri tumor localization and
infiltration of immune cells
um we know that again those infiltrates
and metastatic tumors appear to be
higher
than their non-metastatic primary
counterparts in both species
so a really exciting opportunity to take
this concept forward into a canine
clinical trial
and so i'm really pleased to announce to
everyone today we have cotco 29 which is
going to be a pilot assessment of bg
34200 in metastatic canine osteosarcoma
and broadly speaking the study has three
objectives
uh the first and probably most important
objective of this trial will be to
define the comparative immunological
response to bg34200 in
pet dogs with naturally occurring
metastatic osteosarcoma
through serial interrogation of really
key biologic samples
tumors they're draining lymph nodes
peripheral blood mononuclear cells and
bone marrow
we also are planning to apply molecular
imaging to assess the metabolic tumor
response
and any inflammatory infiltrations that
may change during therapy around
metastatic lesions
and of course critically important to
look at tolerability of the compound
in our patients and to really think
critically about a potential efficacy
signal
on when we apply this therapy
in our patients with metastatic disease
so here's the the proposed trial schema
so lots of exes on this grid and really
that just
drives home the fact that what we're
planning to do is
a lot of very careful assessment of
safety and tolerability using clinical
hematologic and biochemical monitoring
and
you know careful assessment of how dogs
are feeling and how they're
tolerating therapy but also by very
carefully
interrogating these biologic samples
that help us define the immune response
so looking at cytokine profiles and
changes within
immune cells that populate the
peripheral blood and the bone marrow and
then also
the tumor micro environment and draining
lymph nodes we're also planning through
a dose escalation
design to look at pk and then relate the
pk findings to their
pd counterparts pharmacodynamic
counterparts
so that's me actually smiling behind a
mask but
know that these patients that are
enrolled in trials like this are very
carefully monitored and it's really
exciting to then
marry that clinical care to a really
deep assessment of the immunological
response to a really exciting compound
and so even taking it further i think
what we've learned especially
a lot in the last few years is that
there are really exciting opportunities
to investigate immunological
response to therapies like bg 34 200
within this clinical trial schema
one of which um is the new nanostring
encounter canine io panel
so we are looking into the feasibility
of using this panel to look at gene
expression changes that occurred during
therapy with an emphasis on the immune
response genes that are curated within
this panel
so this represents a really exciting
opportunity for us to
look beyond just um measurable changes
in metastatic lesions
um and really get a deeper appreciation
for
the immune response
soul turnover if there's time to alex to
discuss another future direction for a
tgf beta inhibitor
thank you amy this is great um just so
that you know we also
are pursuing a concurrent clinical trial
phase one in human
with bg 34 and the conversation is
ongoing with the fda
but um just to give you a sense of what
is coming up on the horizon in terms of
other ways to manipulate it to my micro
environment with the anastasia sarcoma
and i'll briefly go over the next few
slides one target that we are now
thinking about
in combination with bg34 is to target
the molecule actions of tgf beta which
is a very predominant even of
suppressive
cytokines within the tumor
microenvironment specifically acid
sarcoma
we have a partner now with the mapecto
in south korea who has developed a
first-in-class small molecule inhibitor
that's orally available against
the type 1 tgf beta receptor kinase
vector certified it has a very favorable
pharmacokinetics that's something that
we can adjust very rapidly
uh within 24 48 hours the drug is
flushed out of the system
what we show is that using cga
osteosarcoma model
that vector certa has a very important
in fact inhibiting
phosphosmac2 downstream otg beta
receptor
um and at a 10 10 to 30 nanomolar
dosing range and this is also applicable
in a variety of different osteosarcoma
models
both in in mouse models in this case
as well as in human against human cells
what we saw was again a very potent
inhibition of phosphorus matter
with this diabetic assertive and the
same time in some cell lines
the very interesting characteristics of
down regulating scenic
expression protein expressions and in
vitro it has a direct effect on
limiting the proliferation of human
osteosarcoma cell lines
and in vivo against the genetic mouse
models of osteosarcoma such as k7m2
this orally given vector surge has a
potent inhibition effect
against um an early onset of
osteosarcoma day seven
after tumor inoculation as well as in
the very um
uh delayed onset where the drugs was
given 28 days
after inoculating the tumor and still
has a very important effect
uh in this cgn named house model
against human mouse model are human
models in nsg mouse
again tga beta inhibitor has a very
potent effect
when it's given early in this case after
tumor inoculation
as well as a very late uh rescue attempt
um which we're preventing we are able to
prevent the death of these nsg mouse
bearing
human osteosarcoma even as late as two
months after inoculation
and has a very potent suppression effect
so
just something to keep on on the horizon
and i just want to thank you again for
this opportunity to talk about the bg-34
and potential up upcoming other
molecules that are
aimed at uh changing the
microenvironment of osteosarcoma
and here are the acknowledgement slides
and i will give it back to amy of our
acknowledgement slide
yes so a huge thank you to all the folks
within my group and those that we
collaborate with outside of the nci
very exciting time for us here in
comparative oncology to really partner
with people
like alex and his team at case to really
realize the future of what we can do for
our patients both two-legged and
four-legged
so thanks again for your attention thank
you and we'll take any questions
amy fantastic work clearly more than
just imaging
um i it's cool to see how uh you guys
have taken
a drug from concept through the
pre-clinical work and
into dogs and are working through uh
some of those early studies together
another great example of some
collaborative work between
between human people and veterinary
people
not that veterinary people aren't humans
too um
so i now have the pleasure to introduce
to you
dr william eward
he is one of the rare individuals who is
trained in both
canine and veterinary and
pediatric medicine he has been working
at duke to help develop
a one medicine program where they've
kind of taken a comprehensive approach
to working across this
barrier between veterinary medicine and
pediatric medicine and he's going to
share some of that
work with us today so with that i'll
turn the time over to
will ebert
hello pause for a cure thanks very much
for
having me as one of the speakers my talk
today is called a dog in the cancer
fight
teddy and the consortium for canine
comparative oncology
so like all talks i think the best talk
involves telling a story
and the story of this talk is going to
end up focusing around a golden
retriever named teddy
and what we can learn about cancer from
teddy
especially how we can unite
the problems we face in cancer in people
and in dogs so you'll see teddy you may
see these two
patients here two of my favorite human
and canine patients respectively
and there will be a brief showing by mr
t
so something to look forward to
so i did start out as a veterinarian and
as i became interested in cancer
i crossed over to what we affectionately
called the dark side
the world of human medicine and i always
tell people
that i like having a foot in both worlds
i spend part of my time as a surgical
oncologist at duke
and part of my time as adjunct faculty
at north carolina state
and my heart is really still with the
furry creatures
in large part because they're cuter many
times than the
the human creatures and you never know
what you'll end up doing in the
veterinary world
as opposed to the human world which is
much more predictable but in exchange
there are a greater number of resources
more often than that
the reason i do this is to focus on
comparative oncology
so what can we learn when we compare
cancer in more than one species and most
of what i do involves comparing cancer
in humans
versus humans and dogs now
um my area of expertise is osteosarcoma
and i realize there are a lot of
different types of people in the
audience today i know some of you
are scientists or clinicians um
other people not as much when i talk i
often talk about
two of my favorite patients this girl
kay
with this osteosarcoma that you can see
here in her tibia
and this dog sheba who also has
osteosarcoma in this case
in her forelimb and
these patients both go through the same
thing chemotherapy and surgery
and kay ends up coming out with this
type of reconstruction of her leg and
the cancer is gone and she is
fortunately still alive today
sheba like most dogs even though she
goes through the same fundamental
treatment she ends up with a much
simpler
reconstruction and of course most dogs
get an amputation
and sheba sadly is no longer with us
so i would tell you that these are two
beings
with one cancer osteosarcoma between
humans and dogs
is basically the same thing except we
see it
much more commonly in dogs and that's
true with
with all sarcomas
now here are some survival curves
and these survival curves are looking at
humans with osteosarcoma over the
decades
and the survival before chemotherapy
this red line was very very poor
and as we discovered the role for
chemotherapy
these survival times got better but what
i would point out to you is that the
difference between the green line and
the black line
is almost nil we've made very very few
improvements since the 1980s
and here's the survival curve for dogs
so we see sarcomas in greater numbers of
dogs
and they do much more poorly in case of
osteosarcoma if you're a dog
you are almost certainly going to die
from osteosarcoma
if you're diagnosed with osteosarcoma
so here's a question for everyone in the
audience what things in your life
are the same now as they were in the
1980s
if you were alive in the 1980s
everything has changed the way we
communicate the cars we drive
the video games we play i i promise mr t
would be in the talk here's mr t i would
argue
he has not changed but if you look at
the world of medicine
there's almost nothing in this decade
that is the same as it was in the 1980s
but with sarcomas what i tell
human patients now is very similar to
what they would have been told
in the 1980s
and so the question is how can we do
better at this
we cannot accept this stagnation
and so the rest of this talk is going to
be about
our attempt and our system we have at
duke in north carolina state
to use cross-species comparison to find
a better path forward
so here's just an overview of our system
we've got two big resources one is the
duke comparative oncology group which is
the
group of clinicians and scientists at
duke who are interested
in the field of comparative oncology the
second thing
is the consortium for canine comparative
oncology or as we call it the c3o
and what the c3o does is it formerly
bridges
duke cancer institute and the north
carolina state
college of veterinary medicine it allows
for different status
of faculty between the two schools that
allows for the flow of funds it provides
some common funding
mechanisms and it allows people who
treat one type of cancer in humans
and people who treat cancer in small
animal patients to put their heads
together
and one of the resources that i'm going
to talk to you about in coming minutes
is
a cross-species drug discovery pipeline
or precision medicine pipeline and as we
affectionately
call it the mdh pipeline for mouse dog
human and i'd like to take a minute to
explain how the pipeline works
it works like this so it starts out with
patience
and in our case we are completely
agnostic to whether that patient walks
on two legs
or on full we want to collect
sarcomas from any patient human or
animal and we've got some pretty weird
cancers growing we've actually got
something from a sperm whale growing
at present um the first thing we do
once we get that tissue is we try to
establish it
growing in immunocompromised mice as
pdxs or
patient derived xenografts if you're not
familiar with the lingo
and wherever possible we also establish
cell lines
that are matched to those pdxs and match
to the patients
we then perform high throughput drug
screening
and we do drug screening not only on the
cells from this individual patient
but also on patients of both species
with similar types of cancer
we do genomics usually whole exome
sequencing of tumor and normal tissue
we try to draw conclusions about what
types of responses we're seeing on our
drug screening how that relates
to the genomics of that particular tumor
and then ideally we take this
information and we
return it back to those patients human
or animal
who donated the tissue in the first
place
so how do we use multiple species to
test new targets for
therapy why why is it any better to have
the power of multiple species
and the answer is venn diagrams
and hopefully everyone loves venn
diagrams as much as i do
this is my favorite it's always funny
telling jokes
on zoom meetings because you can't hear
if anyone
laughs or not for me that's probably
good
so here's just an example of some of our
venn diagrams
these are a number of osteosarcoma cell
lines
and this represents a drug screen of
about 800 compounds
and what we've asked is well what drug
was not only effective
against multiple different osteosarcomas
but against osteosarcomas from both
species
and when we see this final overlap of
all of our human cell lines and all of
our canine cell lines
we take this original drug screen number
of about 800 drugs
down to 21 drugs so we go from a number
that's too big to really
study in depth to a number 21 that's
quite reasonable to study
so now i'd like to talk to you about
teddy
teddy was at the time we met him a
three-year-old male golden retriever
and um we met teddy through laura selmac
one of the veterinary surgeons at the
university of illinois
i'm laura i don't know if you're on
today and teddy had developed a wound on
his left stifle
and that's what took him to his
referring veterinarian and at this point
six cutaneous nodules were found all
over his body
the referring veterinarian excised those
they all
were clearly malignant they were all
clearly sarcomas they all had a high
mitotic index
and they all ended up being
lyomyosarcomas
so in other words multiple synchronous
lyomyosarcomas so that's a very unusual
presentation
that leads to teddy being referred to
the university of illinois
where two additional lesions are found
that are also found to be sarcomas
and he's staged and found to have no
evidence of metastasis
um he undergoes clipping of his fur
and a total of nine lesions are found
and they are
all lyromyosarcomas
so what happens next well um
the tumors are sent to us and i'll show
you
more about that pathway but in the
meantime teddy has started
on systemic therapy with palladia or
toserinib
as well as the anti-inflammatory
peroxicam
and his lesions actually regressed
within a period of about two weeks
so now i'll talk to you about the flow
of what's happening with teddy's
visit and its visits and quotes visiting
quotes
because teddy didn't actually come just
his tissue did
so um this tissue comes to the duke
comparative oncology lab
and then a variety of work outputs
happen
so we banked some tumor we banked some
normal tissue
we perform whole exome sequencing
and we start growing our patient-derived
xenographs
i like to give credit where credit is
due this consumed
basically a year and a half of sneha
sneha's life sneha is now a resident
with us at the time she was a medical
student
one of the things she had to do with
every piece of tissue she worked with
that came
out of a mouse was make sure that it was
actually
dog tissue and not mouse tissue so
everything i'm about to show you was a
lot of work by sneha rao
and so the first thing we did is we ran
a hike through
put drug screen and we said well which
drugs are
killing teddy's cancers and
on this plot what i would direct you to
is that here where my cursor is around
the zero that means
no killing minus 10 means the
tumors are actually growing and as we
move up this is what percent of the
cells
are being killed so as you can see most
drugs
are not doing much killing they're a
very small number that are up here in
the 90 to 100 percent
killing range and when we flesh out what
those are
we've created this graph which is
focusing on drugs
where there were multiple drugs that all
were effective killers
and a couple of different targets come
up heat shock protein
plk crm1 the proteasome
kinesin and hdac
but wait if you're following along with
this talk
you're saying well teddy was treated
with teserinib and he had a complete
response
and teserinib is active against vegfr
pdgfr and flt3
and none of those came up so we had the
same thought that's curious he had a
very good response
and by the way if you're on the human
side of the fence palladia
is the sort of cousin compound to sutin
well when we flesh this out and we go
back and look
there was actually a fairly low percent
killing
against the palladia targets you can see
these here
highlighted so the best was flt3
which was still less than 20 killing
so that's a bit of a head scratcher
if we look at some of those higher yield
targets we get these nice
ic50 curves if we look
at tosarinib and sunitnib palladia and
sutent
things are not looking very good and yet
those are the drugs that teddy responded
to
so now we have to consider two
possibilities one
perhaps the cells we have growing from
teddy are not representative
or two perhaps teddy's response was
related to effects on the stroma
or effects otherwise dependent on the
tumor microenvironment
that we really can't capture in in vitro
and in mouse work so
we had the opportunity to look into
those a little bit deeper
we used whole exome sequencing of the
primary tumors the patient derived
xenografts and the cell lines
we did drug testing in pdx bearing mice
and investigations of tumor response as
well as changes in the surrounding
stroma
and here's what we found we found there
was quite a lot of heterogeneity
between teddy's different synchronous
primary tumors
between the pdxs and the primary tumors
and between the cell lines the pdx's and
the primary tumors
so that presents a real challenge
when we tried palladia in our pdx baron
mice we got very erratic responses
unlike teddy who had a very good
response to palladium
and when we look at responses in the
stroma surrounding the tumor we do see
some changes
but not really enough to account for
such a dramatic response as what was
seen in teddy
but meanwhile back at the ranch
teddy relapses he develops more
subcutaneous and intramuscular tumors
and at this point based on the data we
had acquired from our work
we treated him i should say they the
good folks at the university of illinois
treated him
with ortezuma belcade and
interestingly he did have a transient
response but eventually
the tumors started growing in spite of
the bortizumid
and ultimately as is so often the case
teddy died
from relapsed sarcoma so
you may say well you're really ending
with a terrible story why did you tell
me this story
that there actually is is a lot to learn
and i want to just talk about a couple
things on this summary slide i mean
first
this mouse mouse to doctor human
platform
is really working very well and we
appreciate all the people some of whom
are in this audience
who contribute to that
we can use this type of resource for
either cross-species drug screening
in the abstract saying well what drugs
kill all
lyle myosarcomas that we have in canine
and human
tissues but also for precision medicine
approaches to therapy
and we do we do make a big point of
doing what we did for teddy which is
communicating what we learned back to
the treating
condition clinicians excuse me
but teddy really represents an example
of how dogs can help us
much more quickly and much more
effectively
troubleshoot and understand this quest
for precision medicine this idea
that when an individual is diagnosed
with cancer they can get
treatment tailored to them so first of
all there's a faster discovery process
because all of this plays out more
quickly in dogs than it does
in humans in humans we're sometimes
waiting ten years
to see what happens we get these rare
opportunities as was the case in teddy
to observe prison precision medicine
unfold in real time
where we are synchronously in two
different places
observing the patient's response to
treatment
and seeing what the cells in vitro and
in mice
are doing and then lastly for sarcomas
this gives us access to a much greater
numbers of patients
we can do precision medicine in the
human world with things like lung cancer
breast cancer colon cancer
it's much much harder to do it with
sarcomas where we're seeing a relatively
small number um so with that i'm going
to wrap
up there's a big team of people involved
in this
whole process um and i'd like to leave
their smiling faces on the screen
and i look forward to taking your
questions thank you
all right thank you dr eward
i've been a long i've long been an
admirer of your kind of comprehensive
program and approach and
i look forward to talking more about
that here in just a little bit
finally the last presentation for this
session will
come from dr carolyn henry and dr
jeffrey bryan both from the university
of missouri
dr henry is the dean of the college of
veterinary medicine there
and has been the past president of the
veterinary cancer
cancer society and the acbim
and has a long-standing interest in
canine bladder cancer bone and mammary
cancer
and in uh comparative oncology and
epidemiology
dr brian is the director of the
of the program in veterinary oncology
and has a special interest in pet
imaging and other types of imaging
for uh following
cancers and dogs and
in comparative programs
so he also has done some research with
epigenetics and immunotherapies
especially in
hodgkin's lymphoma and we're excited to
hear
what they have to share with us today so
with that i'll turn the time over to dr
henry and dr brian
it seems appropriate that we present
data from our osteosarcoma
study on this last day of childhood
cancer awareness month
spontaneously occurring osteosarcoma in
dogs is a devastating disease
and has been described previously it has
many similarities with the most common
type of bone cancer in children and
teens
it's important to note though that from
its inception
this clinical trial was tumor agnostic
meaning we could have chosen whatever
tumor we wanted to study
we ultimately chose to treat
osteosarcoma but it could have applied
to other tumor types
this really began as an introduction in
kansas city missouri
and it was facilitated by dr wayne
carter who's also joining us today
at the time wayne led the kansas city
area life sciences institute
and he asked me if i would be willing to
meet with tammy wayhouse of tvx
biomedical
he mentioned that they had a unique
immunotherapy approach to cancer and
people
and they might be interested in learning
more about the potential for translation
to animals well the meeting with tammy
and her colleague gary wood was really
the start of a long-standing
relationship between our group at the
university of missouri
and tvx biomedical that culminated with
the launch of elias animal health
and new treatment options and people
in my first email from tammy after our
meeting she said and i've got it here
it was a pleasure to meet your recent
kcalc program
the possibility of testing the tvx
immunotherapy process in animals
to obtain marketing approvals quite
intriguing to us
and a collaboration with a veterinary
school might make a lot of sense
since the tvx team is knowledgeable in
human drug testing and approval process
but not animals we'll have to undertake
a little self-education process before
we can assess whether this is something
that we should pursue and she asked for
reference materials related to that
that was june 27 2013.
and what dr brian's about to present
takes us from that early introduction to
the results of a clinical trial
that has now changed how we treat canine
osteosarcoma
as exciting as that is so is the
completed circle of a
both ends of the leash storyline the
animal health corridor which is centered
in kansas city missouri is the site of
nearly two-thirds of the world's animal
health industry
it's also near several large academic
medical centers and it's a hub for
biotech startups and pharmaceutical
companies
it's this regular networking between
human medical
veterinary and industry partners that
made this type of work possible and i
truly believe that this type of sharing
of expertise and innovative thought
is the key to accelerating medical
progress and discovering cancer cures
for people and animals with that
introduction i'd like to turn it over to
my colleague
dr jeff bryan
thank you carolyn i appreciate the
introduction i'm excited to present the
results of our trial of elias
immunotherapy and dogs with osteosarcoma
and i'll title this vaccine-enhanced
adoptive t-cell therapy with cytokine
boost
for osteosarcoma
i have to admit a conflict of interest
that i am on the elias
scientific advisory board and they have
received travel reimbursements and
honorarium for meetings
but i'm very excited about the
technology that elias
has developed the protocol that a group
of dogs underwent
was to undergo surgery to have
amputation
and to collect tumor material to create
a vaccine series that was administered
to the dogs intradermally
following the vaccine series dogs
underwent apheresis to collect their
peripheral blood lymphocytes
and then these lymphocytes were
activated and expanded ex-vivo in the
laboratory at elias animal health
these activated t-cells were then
infused back into the patients
and the dogs received interleukin-2
injections for five doses over the
following 10 days
they were then followed long term and
did not receive chemotherapy as would be
standard
for their osteosarcoma tumors
eighteen dogs were initially assessed
for eligibility in the trial
four of these dogs were excluded at
screening one dog had a metacrinous
or a metastatic primary bone tumor in
addition to the bone tumor that was
recognized
and three of them had pulmonary
metastases at the time of diagnosis
fourteen dogs entered the trial and all
of them received the autologous
vaccination
the first dog that then received
apheresis and the activated cellular
therapy
had an unexpected reaction to the cell
therapy
it could have been cytokine release
syndrome or some other
transfusion type reaction but the
reaction severity was more severe than
expected and the trial was temporarily
halted
causing one dog to leave the trial at
that time because it was already
enrolled and the trial had been halted
three two other dogs excuse me developed
pulmonary metastasis
before they underwent apheresis and also
exited the trial with early disease
progression
following the halt of the trial a four
dog normal laboratory dog study was
performed that allowed us to evaluate
the efficacy of pre-medicants
to reduce the potential severity of the
infusion of the activated t-cell product
and then the trial was reopened 11 total
dogs
underwent apheresis and activated
cellular therapy
the dog that had the initial reaction
did not receive its il2 injections in
the days following that
reaction so did not receive the full
protocol but ten dogs did
receive the entire protocol of these
dogs
two had disease progression only one had
a
cutaneous metastasis that spontaneously
resolved
another one developed very late
metastasis after two years
and ultimately progressed to death
following the publication
of the manuscript describing the study
four dogs had tumor progression and
death three due to pulmonary metastatic
disease
and one due to pulmonary hepatic and
renal metastasis
at the end of the study the five dogs
were alive and four were disease free
at the time of writing all of them out
past two years
none of them having received
chemotherapy
the four normal dogs that underwent
leukopheresis
ex vivo expansion and then activation of
their t
cells also had their cytokine response
measured
and the cytokines were elevated as
expected in the first 24 hours
following the t-cell infusion
interleukin-2
interleukin-6 interferon gamma and tumor
necrosis factor alpha
were all significantly elevated for the
first 24 hours
and then did return to baseline these
dogs received premedicants with
antihistamines
non-steroidal anti-inflammatories and
showed almost no reaction to
the cytokine to the excuse me to the
adoptive t cell administration
the results of the study were were
interesting
the median disease free interval of the
dogs involved in the study was 213 days
this disease-free interval compares
favorably to a survival of only 134 days
for dogs with amputation alone receiving
no chemotherapy or immunotherapy at the
time of treatment
however the overall median survival of
the 14 dogs in this study
where was 415 days a substantial
improvement
over the 134-day amputation of
survival alone you'll also note that
when you look at the patients that
fail due to progression of disease and
then you look at the survival curve
several of those dogs had rather
extended survival
following the disease progression which
is also not typical course of this
disease
and at the end of this study at the time
that the writing occurred five dogs were
still alive again
past the two-year mark
this study elected to follow outcome of
the dogs
rather than to look specifically at
immune correlative studies
in order to identify real clinical
benefit
to these dogs that had naturally
occurring osteosarcoma
one piece of evidence that suggests that
an immunotherapy
mechanism was indeed in place
was the identification of spontaneous
second remission
of a second of one of the patients this
dog and unfortunately our pet scan is
missing this is a pet scan done
after the dog was determined to no
longer have a cutaneous metastasis
that had been identified by cytological
confirmation of osteosarcoma cells
was then scanned at a later time and
found to have no disease whatsoever in
its body
the most likely explanation of a
spontaneous remission like this
is an immune reaction against the tumor
cells
this dog went on to live an extended
period of time
past two years and never died of
osteosarcoma
so the results of the study were
surprising and very impressive that
immunotherapy alone could benefit more
than amputation alone and in fact the
median survivals compare very favorably
with chemotherapy as well this has been
sufficient evidence to allow elias
animal health to move forward
and offer this on an experimental basis
while their pivotal trial
confirms in comparison to chemotherapy
that indeed the immunotherapy approach
can extend survival
in dogs with osteosarcoma i need to
acknowledge the team that puts so much
work into this
both at mu with dr flesner our nurses
deb tate and anastasia glon
and doctors lindsey donnelly gail
johnson and dr kim
as well as on the elias and tevac side
with dr gary wood
tammy wayhouse who was visionary to
realize that testing this and naturally
occurring disease in the dog
would be potentially beneficial to the
company and
the dr noe reyes and doctors gehart
wallston and dr sonderegger who helped
us with the normal dog study
we also need to acknowledge the patients
at the other end of the leash
that were pioneers for all of us in
understanding this immunological
mechanism
and showing that survival is possible by
using the immunotherapy alone
we are excited about the new
developments
in elias and tvax that are moving us
into other cancers
and training translating this into human
studies and we look forward to more
results from this forward-looking
company
we are happy to take questions from the
audience
all right thank you carolyn and jeffrey
uh we appreciate all these presentations
i think this has been a really
spectacular um illustration of how
canine and human medicine can work
together to solve big problems in
osteosarcoma i wanted to ask something
about
the um
the differences that happen in dogs
versus humans
that might influence the way that we
plan or
interpret uh immuno oncology studies
that are done in dogs maybe uh
uh cheryl and steve can you talk a
little bit about how you
uh and maybe dean a little bit too
especially when we talk about like
cellular therapies right there are some
differences in the way that different
cell types function in dogs versus
humans so how does that affect the way
that you approach
cellular therapies uh and
the way that you uh interpret some of
the results from your studies and how
does that then translate into humans
um
maybe uh alex do you want to talk a
little bit about that and maybe jeffrey
a little bit too
alex and maybe jeffrey a little bit too
i mean i think steve has substantial
differences in
individual cell types and i think you
know those
are ones that have not yet been worked
out i know dean may want to talk a bit
about the nk
differences in dogs versus humans
yeah and i don't think that macrophage
polarization in dogs is as well
understood yet
as it is in humans also and and those
probably play a substantial role too
um but i was fascinated by the nk
discussion earlier and would be very
interested in that insight for sure
and i i would also add that i think we
just know a lot less about those immune
cell subsets
i think you know one of the really big
challenges we have
that has limited our ability to sort of
parse these things out or
the antibody repertoire um that
has you know particularly in things like
the scissor platform that have
really allowed distinct um
characterization and so almost
three-dimensional builds of the immune
have been a little bit challenging for
us which is sort of why we've moved to
the nano platform
that uh is a little bit more
straightforward and
you know although there's bulk analyses
that are being done
we will have a better understanding of
how the union landscape is changing
using the nano
dean how has that journey gone with the
nk cell studies
yeah i mean it was definitely necessary
for us to build
um our own antibodies to detect nk cells
nk cells was already kind of a small
field and not that many people working
on it in the in the dog
um there it'd be good if we had even
more of those antibodies there's a lot
of repertoire
and within the encasal population that
we really don't have an
ability to um to study in the dog
one of the things that's really
different um that
you know just cross species differences
um is that
the primary regulatory receptors for nk
cells
in humans is a family of proteins called
the cure
receptors and in mice is a
um analogous but different family of
proteins
called the life 49 family and some
species have both of those
most of them have one or the other we
don't know what the dog has
the initial dog genome only
characterized one
life 49 gene and it's not clear that
that one's even functional
so there's a lot for us still to learn
uh in order to adapt uh
nk cell therapies in the canine
stephen cheryl i think one of the really
impressive things
from the work that you guys showed is
how quickly you were able to pivot
from one treatment to another to another
in rapid succession
and especially in combinations so doing
combination
drug trials with novel combinations is
challenging
often because you need to come up with
safety data first
so can you talk a little bit about how
you so rapidly went from one combination
to the next and how you ensured that you
were using safe combinations
steve you want to talk about it
yeah i guess one of the strategies we
used i think was to
early on identified drugs that could be
repurposed
so we didn't have to go through the long
regulatory process
so you know so you know early on was
identified as a
drug that we were interested in because
of its target
really it's off target effects and then
we we've expanded out from that with
other drugs such as propranolol and then
the cheryl can address this the uo one
funding mechanism really provided an
opportunity to conduct these rapid small
scale proof of concept trials which
allows us to screen through a number of
promising compounds pretty efficiently
without
committing to large-scale trials and the
risk of
essentially failure so it does allow us
to de-risk
some of these approaches pretty quickly
and cheryl may want to
fill in on that yeah i mean i i think
you know to emphasize sort of what we
said before which is that we just we
wanted to
focus on big hits where we were the
the majority of the patients within a
single cohort
were going to have some benefit not
looking for that incremental 10
there's value in that but i think for us
to move through that ul-1 mechanism at
the end of five years actually have
something that has
impact it was going to require us to
really show
that a substantial portion of the
population was affected and you know
particularly in the setting of
metastatic disease
growth which is in in in canine
and pediatric osteosarcoma particularly
in dogs we're so rapidly progressive
it's so challenging to get any sort of
traction in that setting
if we could show that 30 or more of our
patients were benefiting
by even just stable disease in a setting
where
in two months usually they're not alive
that was a big
a big milestone to achieve and i think
you know we
again it's been an iterative process we
had some things that failed miserably
that we thought would look good and
others that you know were just sort of
random combinations based on what we
thought
happened but i think it was the platform
itself that lent itself to that real
flexibility
agreed i think that disease
stabilization is an interesting thing
particularly when you're looking at
immune mechanisms
and that was something that did surprise
us in in the elias immunotherapy trial
was that
a couple of the dogs that got metastatic
disease
failed relatively early but survived a
surprisingly long time with
with you know really modest disease
progression and obviously it's a small
sample size small number of dogs hard to
determine anything broadly from that but
i'll be very interested as their pivotal
trial moves forward to see
whether they see the same mechanism too
and hopefully with immune mechanisms
we'll see more and more of that of
patients
living with disease longer and more
comfortably than just dying a disease
quickly which is what we have seen as
the norm for so many years
dr eward um as i mentioned i've long
been an admirer of kind of this
comprehensive program that you guys have
built at duke as what i know it's still
kind of early but i was wondering if you
had any really good examples of ways
that the things that you found in the
dogs have
has kind of cross fertilized into the
things that you've
found or done in the humans or vice
versa
um yeah thanks for the kind words ryan
hi everyone good to see everyone um
likewise thanks one of the
i think one of the more interesting
stories we've had here that we're just
starting to get out
into the literature is there's this um
ant helmintic that you guys may know
called naclosamide and the close mind
was
invented decades ago it's got really
potent anti-cancer properties but it's
so hydrophobic that it's not really
bioavailable
and um we worked with a physical chemist
to make a new formulation of it through
a process called rapid solvent exchange
where
basically we esterify the naclosamide so
we make a new molecule that's less
hydrophobic
and um we were getting really good
results in vitro
and in mice in osteosarcoma but
you know we're missing this key step to
go from what we have in mice
to then offering it to um to humans
so working with steve suter at nc state
we started offering this in a pilot
trial to a small number of dogs with
osteosarcoma
and we've gotten really good results
and i think this is just a type of
homegrown trial
that you can do with the right
um the right collaborative network set
in place
that inches us forward to offering new
things like this in humans things that
you can
develop on your own at your university
and move pretty far along the
translational railroad
i think you're on mute ryan
hey thank you thank you i was uh
thinking about where this is going
there's a really nice question asked by
one of the participants
uh about kind of trends over time so
there is this trend toward more people
getting insurance for their pet animals
right
and maybe seeking more care for things
that they might otherwise
not have so maybe amy and carolyn can
you speak a little bit
to kind of trends that you see and
whether you see more people wanting to
treat a dog with cancer
and whether or not that feeds into the
opportunities that we have in terms of
studies
and and where we kind of see this going
uh well gosh i haven't been in the
clinic in a few years but i would say
you know there's definitely evidence
that people are more invested in the
care of their pets as members of their
family
so i think clearly we as a community
across veterinary medicine
see that that trend of the pet being a
part of the family and there being a
real investment in the
care um has certainly grows alongside
you know third-party payment
opportunities but i know carolyn what do
you think
i i think one thing that we've noticed
in light of the pandemic is
veterinary medicine has just exploded
and i think part of that is
people ended up adopting animals they're
around their animals more
so they are probably noticing things
they didn't used to so
i i don't see anything but growth in
this area and i think there's a demand
for similar therapies as to what you can
see in people if you told me
20 years ago that people would be doing
apheresis on their dogs and
immunotherapy with cancer i would have
told you you were crazy but
you know we have those cases showing up
every day so
it's nothing but growth on our side of
things
well thank you everyone i i want to
thank all of the presenters today for
taking the time to prepare their talks
and for
participating in the discussion and i
want to thank all the participants
i want to remind everyone that there are
some fantastic posters out in the lobby
if you go to the poster session
so be sure to take a chance to to
catch some of those posters and you can
have opportunities to interact with
those presenters as well through the
chat function
so this will be the end of this session
with one more session to go
so thank you everyone for participating
and we'll see you around
thanks